But what we saw is, in the post-9/11 era,
they used secrecy and they used the justification of terrorism
to start these programs in secret
without asking Congress,
without asking the American people,
and it's that kind of government behind closed doors
that we need to guard ourselves against,
because it makes us less safe,
and it offers no value.
CA: Okay, come with me here for a sec,
because I've got a more personal question for you.
Speaking of terror,
most people would find the situation you're in right now
in Russia pretty terrifying.
You obviously heard what happened,
what the treatment that Bradley Manning got,
Chelsea Manning as now is,
and there was a story in Buzzfeed saying that
there are people in the intelligence community
who want you dead.
How are you coping with this?
How are you coping with the fear?
ES: It's no mystery
that there are governments out there that want to see me dead.
I've made clear again and again and again
that I go to sleep every morning
thinking about what I can do for the American people.
I don't want to harm my government.
I want to help my government,
but the fact that they are willing to
completely ignore due process,
they're willing to declare guilt
without ever seeing a trial,
these are things that we need to work against
as a society, and say hey, this is not appropriate.
We shouldn't be threatening dissidents.
We shouldn't be criminalizing journalism.
And whatever part I can do to see that end,
I'm happy to do despite the risks.
CA: So I'd actually like to get some feedback
from the audience here,
because I know there's widely differing reactions
to Edward Snowden.
Suppose you had the following two choices, right?
You could view what he did
as fundamentally a reckless act
that has endangered America
or you could view it as fundamentally a heroic act
that will work towards America and the world's
long-term good?
Those are the two choices I'll give you.
I'm curious to see who's willing to vote with
the first of those,
that this was a reckless act?
There are some hands going up.
Some hands going up.
It's hard to put your hand up
when the man is standing right here,
but I see them.
ES: I can see you. (Laughter)
CA: And who goes with the second choice,
the fundamentally heroic act?
(Applause) (Cheers)
And I think it's true to say that there are a lot of people
who didn't show a hand and I think
are still thinking this through,
because it seems to me that the debate around you
doesn't split along traditional political lines.
It's not left or right, it's not really about
pro-government, libertarian, or not just that.
Part of it is almost a generational issue.
You're part of a generation that grew up
with the Internet, and it seems as if
you become offended at almost a visceral level
when you see something done
that you think will harm the Internet.
Is there some truth to that?
ES: It is. I think it's very true.
This is not a left or right issue.
Our basic freedoms, and when I say our,
I don't just mean Americans,
I mean people around the world,
it's not a partisan issue.
These are things that all people believe,
and it's up to all of us to protect them,
and to people who have seen and enjoyed
a free and open Internet,
it's up to us to preserve that liberty
for the next generation to enjoy,
and if we don't change things,
if we don't stand up to make the changes
we need to do to keep the Internet safe,
not just for us but for everyone,
we're going to lose that,
and that would be a tremendous loss,
not just for us, but for the world.
CA: Well, I have heard similar language recently
from the founder of the world wide web,
who I actually think is with us, Sir Tim Berners-Lee.
Tim, actually, would you like to come up and say,
do we have a microphone for Tim?
(Applause)
Tim, good to see you. Come up there.
Which camp are you in, by the way,
traitor, hero? I have a theory on this, but --
Tim Berners-Lee: I've given much longer
answers to that question, but hero,
if I have to make the choice between the two.
CA: And Ed, I think you've read
the proposal that Sir Tim has talked about
about a new Magna Carta to take back the Internet.
Is that something that makes sense?
ES: Absolutely. I mean, my generation, I grew up
not just thinking about the Internet,
but I grew up in the Internet,
and although I never expected to have the chance
to defend it in such a direct and practical manner
and to embody it in this unusual,
almost avatar manner,
I think there's something poetic about the fact that
one of the sons of the Internet
has actually become close to the Internet
as a result of their political expression.
And I believe that a Magna Carta for the Internet
is exactly what we need.
We need to encode our values
not just in writing but in the structure of the Internet,
and it's something that I hope,
I invite everyone in the audience,
not just here in Vancouver but around the world,
to join and participate in.
CA: Do you have a question for Ed?
TBL: Well, two questions,
a general question —
CA: Ed, can you still hear us?
ES: Yes, I can hear you. CA: Oh, he's back.
TBL: The wiretap on your line
got a little interfered with for a moment.
(Laughter)
ES: It's a little bit of an NSA problem.
TBL: So, from the 25 years,
stepping back and thinking,
what would you think would be
the best that we could achieve
from all the discussions that we have
about the web we want?
ES: When we think about
in terms of how far we can go,
I think that's a question that's really only limited
by what we're willing to put into it.
I think the Internet that we've enjoyed in the past
has been exactly what we as not just a nation
but as a people around the world need,
and by cooperating, by engaging not just
the technical parts of society,
but as you said, the users,
the people around the world who contribute
through the Internet, through social media,
who just check the weather,
who rely on it every day as a part of their life,
to champion that.
We'll get not just the Internet we've had,
but a better Internet, a better now,
something that we can use to build a future
that'll be better not just than what we hoped for
but anything that we could have imagined.
CA: It's 30 years ago that TED was founded, 1984.
A lot of the conversation since then has been
along the lines that
actually George Orwell got it wrong.
It's not Big Brother watching us.
We, through the power of the web,
and transparency, are now watching Big Brother.
Your revelations kind of drove a stake
through the heart of that rather optimistic view,
but you still believe there's a way of doing something
about that.
And you do too.
ES: Right, so there is an argument to be made
that the powers of Big Brother have increased enormously.
There was a recent legal article at Yale
that established something called the Bankston-Soltani Principle,
which is that our expectation of privacy is violated
when the capabilities of government surveillance
have become cheaper by an order of magnitude,
and each time that occurs, we need to revisit
and rebalance our privacy rights.
Now, that hasn't happened since
the government's surveillance powers
have increased by several orders of magnitude,
and that's why we're in the problem that we're in today,
but there is still hope,
because the power of individuals
have also been increased by technology.
I am living proof
that an individual can go head to head
against the most powerful adversaries
and the most powerful intelligence agencies
around the world and win,
and I think that's something
that we need to take hope from,
and we need to build on
to make it accessible not just to technical experts
but to ordinary citizens around the world.
Journalism is not a crime,
communication is not a crime,
and we should not be monitored in our everyday activities.
CA: I'm not quite sure how you shake the hand of a bot,
but I imagine it's, this is the hand right here. TBL: That'll come very soon.
ES: Nice to meet you,
and I hope my beam looks as nice
as my view of you guys does.
CA: Thank you, Tim.
(Applause)
I mean, The New York Times recently called for an amnesty for you.
Would you welcome the chance to come back to America?
ES: Absolutely. There's really no question,
the principles that have been the foundation
of this project
have been the public interest
and the principles that underly
the journalistic establishment in the United States
and around the world,
and I think if the press is now saying,
we support this,
this is something that needed to happen,
that's a powerful argument, but it's not the final argument,
and I think that's something that public should decide.
But at the same time,
the government has hinted that they want
some kind of deal,
that they want me to compromise
the journalists with which I've been working,
to come back,
and I want to make it very clear
that I did not do this to be safe.
I did this to do what was right,
and I'm not going to stop my work
in the public interest
just to benefit myself.
(Applause)
CA: In the meantime,
courtesy of the Internet and this technology,
you're here, back in North America,
not quite the U.S., Canada, in this form.
I'm curious, how does that feel?
ES: Canada is different than what I expected.
It's a lot warmer.
(Laughter)
CA: At TED, the mission is "ideas worth spreading."
If you could encapsulate it in a single idea,
what is your idea worth spreading
right now at this moment?
ES: I would say the last year has been a reminder
that democracy may die behind closed doors,
but we as individuals are born
behind those same closed doors,
and we don't have to give up
our privacy to have good government.
We don't have to give up our liberty
to have security.
And I think by working together
we can have both open government
and private lives,
and I look forward to working with everyone
around the world to see that happen.
Thank you very much.
CA: Ed, thank you.
(Applause)